there's been videos that like i see now
of myself and i'm like i can't believe
that exists on the internet i really
went all in let's just say that hi i'm
addison ray and this is my glamifesto
for life my daily mantra is
i am beautiful the way i am
the best tips to clap back against
misogyny is probably
success
proving that you can do anything you
want to do with no limitations my
favorite video i have recorded on tick
tock hands down is probably say one of
my like very first ones like the video
my mom and i did to mariah carey's
obsessed because she liked the video and
that was like a first big moment for me
to like realize that someone that i had
looked up to for a long time noticed me
the secret to a thriving tech talk
career is
i will say probably just like being
yourself that's so cliche and like
everyone says be yourself but i think
people are attracted to seeing things
that are unique to different people but
also like relatable the hardest dance
i've taught myself for tick tock i'm
gonna say [ __ ] not because it was hard
but just because it was like the high
kick in the beginning the
split on the ground just different
things like that it was definitely more
like advanced as far as kickback dances
whenever it was first like becoming a
thing the video i regret most recording
um there's been videos that like i see
now of myself and i'm like i can't
believe that exists on the internet it's
not even if the dance is embarrassing
it's just like i really went all in
let's just say that so i'll look at it
and be like
oh gosh here we go again
the best lesson i've learned from my
mother is probably don't
be afraid to be who you are because that
is simply who you are and don't let
people take that away from you um i
think people especially nowadays try and
convince everyone like they need to be
the same and perfect and great all the
time and no one makes mistakes and i
think just knowing who you are and like
staying true to that and not letting
people tell you who you are which i feel
like is a big trend nowadays to tell
people who they are and what they should
be doing and what they should be wearing
and what they should look like and this
and that and what their body should be
like it's like such a big thing right
now i see videos all the time where it's
like i don't like this girl's outfit at
all like she should wear something like
this and it's like
no like you can wear what you want to
wear and wear what you're comfortable
wearing and no one should tell you what
you should or shouldn't wear or what you
look good in because if you feel
confident in it then doesn't matter
pandorami is all about individuality and
expressing yourself through
um just different types of medallions
and dangles and things like that that
can use a lot of different diversity in
them
if my beauty cabinet was on fire
hopefully that never happens knock on
wood i would save my
probably
my mascara my item beauty mascara
the best wellness hack i've learned from
courtney is probably i guess just like
working out why it's like doing pilates
i feel like i really started getting
into pilates whenever i was working out
with courtney a lot and then we'd do
pilates and also run which i hate
running but it's so good for you
i feel most empowered when i am doing
things that i love to do so dancing
singing being like creative i feel very
empowered and i'm creative my favorite
song to sing is
i love to sing the song wait by maroon 5
featuring a boogie with the hoodie
because i like his purse
the best makeup trend i found on tick
tock is probably like a negative space
eyeliner i think that's really cool and
i've seen like a lot of kind of makeup
hacks with eyeliner like right now
there's this one where you like put
white dots like surrounding your eye and
people are like it'll get people to look
at you in your eyes i think that makes
sense because if you have like a crazy
eyeliner or like eye look on then people
will look at your eyes so i guess it
works glamour to me means just
expressing yourself in the ways that
make you feel confident and beautiful
and glamorous if you will glamour is
just yeah loving yourself and who you
are and expressing that through creative
forms such as fashion makeup i take care
of my mental health by spending time
with people i love and
probably like
doing pilates i feel like that's one
thing i kind of like get away from
reality in a little bit is like work out
spend time with my friends while i'm
there i do classes with my friends which
i really like
my instant mood booster is
probably listening to music
the best hack i've learned from tik tok
is probably how to make like full meals
out of like very simple ingredients
there's like this salmon
salmon and rice like
steamed rice that people are doing a lot
now i'm not much of a cook but my mom is
so i'm learning from tick tock instead
of my mom being invited to the met gala
made me feel
so many things i would say probably just
proud of myself i think i was really
proud of myself for
getting there i had wrote down in like a
dream journal years and years ago like
i'll go to the met gala like bucket list
or like things i want to do in my life i
did think it was gonna happen i don't
know it's that weird thing of like you
know something's gonna happen in your
life like i know i'm gonna make this
happen but also like is it gonna happen
you know like am i sure um but then it
did and it kind of showed myself that
like i can accomplish anything that i
really put my mind to and um and you can
too